BUT FIRST, THE RED STATES CARE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES IN
BIG TECH HAVE BECOME INCREDIBLY
HOSTILE TOWARD ROUGHLY HALF THE
COUNTRY.
AFTER YEARS OF PEACEFUL DRUM
RALLIES AND EARLY TEA PARTY
EVENTS, THE JANUARY 6 CAPITAL
RIOT WAS A GIFT TO DEMOCRATS.
IT GAVE THEM THE VIDEO AND THE
NARRATIVE THAT THEY DESPERATELY
WANTED AND NEEDED TO JUSTIFY A
CRACKDOWN ON THE CIVIL LIBERTIES
OF ALL CONSERVATIVES.
IT’S COMING FROM THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, STARTING AT THE
DOJ.
BIDEN’S ATTORNEY GENERAL
BELIEVES THAT JANUARY 6 WAS
WORSE THAN THE OKLAHOMA CITY
BOMBING THAT KILLED MORE THAN
150 AMERICANS INCLUDING CHILDREN
.
>> WHERE FACING A MORE DANGEROUS
PERIOD THAN WE’VE FACED IN A
GLOW MISS IT A BREAK I PLAN TO
GIVE THE CAREER PROSECUTORS
WORKING ON THIS MATTER 24/7 ALL
THE RESOURCES THEY COULD
POSSIBLY REQUIRED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE LOOK MORE BROADLY TO
LOOK AT WHERE THIS IS COMING
FROM, WHAT OTHER GROUPS THERE
MAY BE THAT COULD RAISE THE SAME
PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE.
I KNOW THE FBI DIRECTOR HAS MADE
THE SAME COMMITMENT.
>> WHAT DID JUDGE GARLAND MEAN
BY QUOTE LOOKING MORE BROADLY.
IS THAT MORE DOMESTIC
SURVEILLANCE, LOWER PROBABLE
CAUSE STANDARDS?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PATRIOT ACT
ON STEROIDS.
DEMOCRATS USED TO OPPOSE
GOVERNMENT OVERREACH LIKE THIS
BUT ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY, THEY
WERE EMBRACING IT.
>> DOMESTIC TERRORISM IS NOT A
NEW THREAT, BUT IT’S AN URGENT
THREAT THAT WILL REQUIRE SERIOUS
FOCUS TO ENSURE WE’RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
THEIR SAFETY AND SECURITY OF ALL
AMERICANS.
EVERY SENATOR HERE TODAY TOOK AN
O’S TO PROTECT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
BOTH FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
TODAY’S HEARING IS OUR FIRST ON
JANUARY 6 ATTACK, IT WILL NOT BE
OUR LAST.
>> BY THE WAY, THESE SAME
SENATORS WHO WENT ON ABOUT
PREVENTING DOMESTIC TERRORISM
THEY DIDN’T HAVE A PROBLEM AS I
COULD TELL WITH NT FIVE.
THEY ALSO HAVE NO QUALMS WITH
WITH BIDENS GETTING UP OUR
BORDER ENFORCEMENT MAKING IT A
CINCH FOR TERRORISTS TO ENTER
AMERICAN AND FOR ILLEGAL ALIEN
CRIMINALS TO AVOID DEPORTATION.
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING OF
COURSE ISN’T ABOUT YOUR SECURITY
.
IT’S ABOUT CRIMINALIZING AN
ENTIRE POLITICAL MOVEMENT IN
AMERICA.
YOU DON’T NEED HEARINGS TO NO
DEDICATED MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
CAPITOL POLICE WERE OVERWHELMED
AND UNPREPARED FOR A BREACH.
>> YOUR INTELLIGENCE FOLKS ON
JANUARY 3RD, THE INTELLIGENCE
DIVISION OF THE CAPITOL POLICE
ISSUED AN INTERNAL REPORT WHICH
STATED THE PROUD BOYS, WHITES
ARE PREMISED GROUPS, OTHER
EXTREMISTS GROSSED WOULD BE IN
PUBLIC SOURCES MAY BE INCLINED
TO BECOME VIOLENT.
SO YOU HAVE YOUR OWN REPORT, DID
YOU SEE THAT REPORT THAT WAS PUT
OUT ON THE THIRD?
HOW WAS THAT NOT A WARNING SIGN,
AND IF IT WAS, WHAT DID YOU DO
WHEN YOU READ THAT REPORT?
>> UNREAL, THEY HAVE THE REPORTS
.
BUT THE SOLUTION OFFERED FOR
PREVENTING FUTURE BREACHES OF
THE CAPITAL IS SURVEILLANCE OF
MORE AMERICANS?
>> I THINK MY BIG CONCERN IS ON
THE COLLECTION, ON HOW WIDE WE
ARE CASTING THE NET THAT WOULD
HAVE REVEALED THIS WAS COMING
AND WE WERE FACING THIS TYPE OF.
>> FIRST OF ALL, ANYONE WHO HAS
STUDIED ARMED INSURRECTION
THROUGHOUT HISTORY KNOWS THAT
THIS ONE WAS PRETTY LAME KITE BY
COMPARISON.
IT WAS DESPICABLE, CRIMINAL, AND
INFURIATING, BUT A RIOT.
THE ONLY PERSON SHOT INSIDE THE
CAPITAL WAS IN AN ARMED AIR
FORCE VET NAMED ASHLEY BABBITT.
EYES DON’T THINK WE STILL KNOW
WHO THE OFFICER WAS THAT SHOT
HER OR THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING WHY HE DID IT.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN THE AFTER ACTION
REPORT ON HER TO HAVE.
THE LOSS OF LIFE THAT OCCURRED
THAT DAY IS STILL SHROUDED IN
MYSTERY.
FROM THE GET-GO, THE MEDIA SAW
THE TRAGIC DAY AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TRUMP COLLATION AS A BUNCH OF
HEINOUS TERRORIST.
PROSSER REPORTS CIRCULATED FOR
WEEKS CLAIMING THAT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS SMASHED OVER THE HEAD
WITH A FIRE EXTINCTION OR
KILLING HIM.
NOW, THAT IS EVEN CALLED INTO
QUESTION.
HOW CAN THIS BE?
WE STILL DON’T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE OFFICER’S CAUSE OF
DEATH?
BUT WE KNOW THE ENTIRE LIFE
STORY OF THE IDIOT IN THE
BUFFALO GET UP AND FACE PAINT?
YOU GET THE GIST.
TO BED, IF YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP,
IF YOU ENDED AT TRUMP RALLY OR
HAD SUPPORT FOR HIS AGENDA,
YOU’RE COMPLICIT.
YOU’RE COMPLICIT IN THE ATTACK
AND NEED TO BE SHUNNED FROM
SOCIETY, LOSE YOUR JOB, AND
BEYOND BAND FROM SOCIAL MEDIA
INDEFINITELY.
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF THEIR
BENEFACTORS IN BIG TECH, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING OVERTIME
TO FRIGHTEN GOOD PATRIOTIC
AMERICANS WHO FOR EXERCISING
THEIR FREEDOM.
THEY WANT TO MAKE YOU FEARFUL OF
SPEAKING OUT, OF SHARING YOUR
VIEWS ONLINE, OF ATTENDING
PEACEFULLY ATTENDING RALLIES.
AND IT ALL BEGINS TO FEEL LIKE A
POLICE STATE ENVIRONMENT.
IN WASHINGTON, IT ALREADY IS.
LOOK AT WHAT WE’VE COME TO.
THESE MILITARY VEHICLES AND
RAZOR WIRE ARE HERE FOR ONE
REASON AND ONE REASON ONLY.
BECAUSE PELOSI AND COMPANY WANT
YOU TO THINK THAT PRO TRUMP
INSURRECTIONIST ARE PLOTTING
RIGHT AT THIS VERY MOMENT.
TO OVERTHROW CONGRESS.
THEY KNOW THAT’S NOT TRUE.
IT’S A TOTAL LIE.
IF YOU SENATORS, THEY SEE HOW
THIS COULD ALL BACKFIRE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> HOW DO WE PROTECT THE CAPITAL
FROM EITHER AN ANGRY MOB, OR
PROBABLY MORE LIKELY ONE, TWO,
THREE MALIGNANT ACTORS WITHOUT
TURNING IT INTO A FORTRESS.
>> I THINK THERE ARE OPTIONS FOR
MAINTAINING AN OPEN ENVIRONMENT
AND OPEN CAMPUS TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT WHILE PUTTING
SUBSTANTIAL PHYSICAL SECURITY
MEASURES IN PLACE BOTH FOR THE
BUILDING, AS WELL AS FARTHER OUT
.
TIME AND DISTANCES ARE BEST
FRIENDS.
>> THEY WANT TO KEEP AMERICAN
CITIZENS FROM HAVING THE FREEDOM
TO WALK AROUND CAPITOL HILL, TO
ASSEMBLY PEACEFULLY NEAR THE
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WORK FOR
THEM FOR EIGHT UNDER JANUARY 6,
WE HAD A PROBLEM WITH WHAT ABOUT
800 PEOPLE?
OUT OF A COUNTRY OF 330 MILLION.
BUT WE ARE A FREE PEOPLE.
WE ARE FREE TO SPEAK OUT, WE’RE
FREE TO PETITION THE GOVERNMENT
FOR EIGHT WE ARE FREE TO
ASSEMBLE, TRAVEL, AND WORSHIP.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, WHAT
WE’RE WITNESSING AT ALL LEVELS
OF SOCIETY RUN BY LIBERALS IS A
NEW RED SCARE.
INSTEAD OF TARGETING MARXIST,
THEY’RE FIGHTING AMERICANS IN
RED STATES.
IN THIS ENTIRE CHARADE ON
CAPITOL HILL IS DESIGNED FOR
BOTH BID THE PEOPLE FROM
ASSEMBLING.
SO NO MORE RALLIES, NO MORE
ORGANIZING YOUR BOAT BREEDS
ONLINE BREAK THAT’S ALL DOMESTIC
TERRORISM NOW.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO USE
COVID TO KEEP YOU HOME, SO NOW,
THEY HAVE COME UP WITH A FAR
MORE MORE FAR-REACHING.
SCARE TACTICS ARE ALL THEY HAVE.
THE STATES THEY RUN ARE
TEETERING ON AGE, NEW YORK IS
FAILING, CALIFORNIA, THAT’S
FAILING, ILLINOIS IS A TOTAL
MESS.
MICHIGAN ISN’T FAR BEHIND.
NEW ENGLAND, WHERE I’M FROM HAS
LOST ITS MANUFACTURING BASE, ITS
FOUNDING AND HIGH TAXES.
JUST LIKE THEIR COVID LOCKDOWN,
DEMOCRATS EFFORTS TO
DECRIMINALIZE THE AMERICA FIRST
MOVEMENT GOING TO CRASH AND BURN
.
THESE ATTEMPTS TO LIMIT THE FREE
SPEECH OF’S CITIZENS WILL RUN
INTO THE BUZZ ALL OF THOSE 200
FEDERAL JUDGES APPOINTED BY
DONALD TRUMP.
SOON THIS IS ALSO GOING TO HAVE
BEEN.
THE WEATHER IS GOING TO GET
BETTER AND WHEN IT DOES, ALL
THOSE LEFT-WING’S PROTESTS ARE
GOING TO RETURN.
AND THEN, ONCE AGAIN, WE WILL
SEE WHAT A BUNCH OF FRAUDS THE
DEMOCRATS REALLY ARE.
SUDDENLY ALL THE LIBERAL